lento regreso a la normalidad en
kazajistán las tropas rusas deberían
empezar a abandonar la nación en los
próximos dos días más de 2.000 soldados
fueron enviados para sofocar las
protestas en la antigua nación soviética
según el presidente de kazajistán casi
en llamar tokáyev será de manera gradual
la retirada se completará en 10 días el
presidente había acusado a extranjeros
armados de supuestamente aprovecharse de
la situación para intentar hacerse al
poder
un grupo de militantes armados que
estaba esperando entre bastidores se
unió a la acción el objetivo principal
se hizo evidente el socavamiento del
orden constitucional la destrucción de
las instituciones de gobierno la toma
del poder estamos hablando de un intento
de golpe de estado
las protestas que empezaron el 2 de
enero fueron desencadenadas por la
subida del precio del combustible
decenas de personas murieron en los
enfrentamientos se quemaron edificios y
saquearon tiendas el presidente de rusia
vladimir putin había afirmado
anteriormente que quería detener los
intentos de los extranjeros de
interferir en los asuntos internos esto
para no dejar que nadie se estabilice la
situación en nuestra casa e implemente
los llamados escenarios de la revolución
de colores más de 10.000 personas han
sido detenidas por la policía durante
las protestas sin embargo los motivos
del malestar siguen el estancamiento de
los salarios y el aumento del costo de
vida así como el aumento del desempleo
entre los jóvenes